I hope I've
explained about my views on why we
cannot go
back we've also been moving forward as
teachers I
believe not because we are wrong but
because the INF uences of our students
and the desire to keep
them has
perhaps
increased the value of our
teaching I now
have um been thinking a lot
about who can we teach what can we
give many
people I've met around the world
aoka like me and dislike
me they dislike me mainly because over
the years I haven't thought about what I
should say before I say it and if I
see what I call bad iido
techniques or poor students not
concentrating or talk talking to each
other on the map when they should be
training hard I just tell them I pull
them out even out into the middle of the
the class and say this is not the way to
do this technique look at it it will
never work in a real
situation iido has been criticized
because it won't work in 99% of the the
cases because the people are not doing a
martial art anymore
some of the teachers who have been
taught by cyto sensey the same as me
have have modified their
iido because their heart has moved on
their love has moved
on they want they' they've touched the
spiritual side of
IO and they've
found that it's it's leaped leaped them
forward into wanting peace and Harmony
and beauty within the art of
iido they don't realize they destroyed
it and ruining it
for those that while KN shean wants to
bring
back but perhaps he's
also
helped ruin
it such as myself and all you teachers
who are listening to
me the
students we try to keep and we look at
them and we realize they're not the
hardcore that perhaps we once
were and the world that comes to M Now
everywhere I go in the western world
where
democracies are
thriving we have to be
careful the buzz word is
well-being we have to have the
well-being
thoughts of our
students so why are we doing it and
calling it a martial
art we could call it moving yoga flowing
yoga
a dance that doesn't have a name like
the Tango we could call it
iido there's there is good reason why
criticism has been brought
upon iido and we've all helped to do
this in the UK now if we have a seminar
it's very rare that you will have a
two-day
seminar if some a Japanese teacher comes
from the hu Dojo it
will get a a massive
attendance it will run for perhaps two
three
days but for normal
teachers such as
myself where we used to get 100 120
people then it dropped to 80 now I'm
happy getting as many as 30 people I
think that's a really good
turnout if you get students coming from
abroad because you've got lots of
different
contacts you'll per still get upwards to
100 on a
seminar and amongst those there'll be
some very dedicated
students it's very hard to
find the students who are still
training every day of the week toning
their body giving time for
meditation looking for the spiritual
path as
well and doing their own thing as much
off the map that's on
it if we we run a weekend seminar here
in the UK and I don't know about your
own
countries the Saturday will
have different people than the
Sunday yes there'll be a few that go to
both but we're talking a very
few one of the reasons is age the
population of aikidoka now are getting
old and their bodies just can't take the
training for two whole
days we used to have 6 hours a day
training sometimes more but the average
was about six now it seems to be reduced
to four five at the
[Music]
most we're having to have this word well
being thought of all the time oh well
they're getting older
now it's getting hard hard to find new
case that you can do demonstrations with
who go through the air a few meters
before they land and come up and repeat
it over and over
again you possibly think what a negative
person I am the way I'm speaking but I'm
just responding to what I
see I see lots of YouTube films of
classes
seminars nobody seems to have the
bulging a following that there was
once going back to the early days in
Russia and thinking that oh these are 50
years
[Music]
minimum behind us in the UK
reminds me of how I was when I first
started at
23 the Woman's Place was in her home
she'd do the cooking and she would look
after the children and the men would go
to work and do what they needed to do
and then they'd have their Hobbies
playing dance going to the pub going to
the football matches doing iido doing k
you name it the
man done his thing the woman done her
thing nowadays everything's completely
changed
and we've gone so far and so
fast
that why one of the reasons the husband
can't go to two days of a seminar even
if they were f get enough young enough
and
wanted is they have
commitments the wife has to work perhaps
and she picks the children up or perhaps
the man picks the children
up it doesn't matter if it's man and man
living together woman and woman living
together they still have the same roles
where they're sharing more and the and
you don't need me to be telling you this
you know it
but when I've heard the man in this
particular case come up to me and said I
can't make it tomorrow it's my day for
the
children so you
see the the part that I'm
reading about what ju
Shan tells us what we need to integrate
back into the teaching of the
aoka it cannot ever be reverse we cannot
go back because we've gone forward the
best we can
do is try to
teach but we've got to teach perhaps
what ensi really
wanted we've got to become more
spiritual we've got to be more caring
we've got to care about the people we're
teaching and the
techniques I think should
become not secondary but just a small
section of what we're
giving I believe that we should and
nobody likes the warmups and the
stretching I can see the people's faces
because they're not
flexible they just want to get on with
the io the techniques the throwing the
fun they don't want to think about
stretching their body warming their body
up and enjoying that
part if we have a
meditation of calming down at the end of
class it lasts a few minutes you can't
be there long because you're paying an
extortion and rent perhaps to half the
hall you can't just sit there in
meditation 30
minutes
and if you did sit there it'd be far too
painful because nowadays people can't
sit in
CER for any time at all we used to have
to sit in CER for 30 45 minutes if since
they wanted to give us a
lecture yes it was painful
we didn't enjoy
it so what you done was you went home
and you would kneel on the
carpet from time to time stretching the
ankles out so that you wouldn't be in
pain because you knew that the endurance
of having to sit there and listen to the
Sensei was going to
happen a mind would be on the pain but
because as we were Desiring to be as
good as the
senses that were in front of us we would
want what they got to give us far more
than the pain we were
enduring this Dojo is very beautiful
this has a a wonderful aura about
it and not only will I get this
wonderful feeling each time I walk in
here
but I'm hoping that those who visit it
will also get inspired and feel
it I'd like to move on
to I often
wonder if I came into the
universe too late or too
early I say this because
I often think the world is going too
fast for me to keep Pace with
it I find myself as bad as everybody
else I don't want to listen to a long
film or
podcast I don't mind listening like
perhaps you're listening now if I'm busy
doing something but I haven't got time
to sit why should I sit when I've got so
many other things to
do you know shall I join Tik Tok
WhatsApp Instagram X now it's
called messenger
Facebook you know anything else that
meta has got to get off for
us and then there's my grandchildren
with all sorts of
apps talking to and sending me
all pups as they call me join this and
then we can
chat and
yet I'm already chatting on so many
things that I haven't got time to
breathe or
relax I'm even having
troubles trying to read a book from
start to finish
in what I call a sens of time
frame does this sound like poor little
old me or does it sound like what you're
going through what your life is so if
I'd have come
out at the wrong time into the universe
originally and I'm finding that the
speed of the world is far too fast for
me
perhaps I should have been
born 10 years or 20 years before so that
the pace that I'm traveling at or wish
to think that I could travel at would be
more agreeable to
me something I could keep control of
rather than feel that whatever I do
there'll be a bigger mountain to climb
tomorrow with things to do than I'm
doing
today is it the Western world has given
us too much too
fast and these countries who are behind
us should we encourage them to get what
we have or to treasure what they've
got my own view is
let them have what we have
because this is
evolution and the dictators of this
world holding their people really in
their
prisons could do so much
better again it's political but look at
South Korea and North
Korea they it was one
country look at how North
Korea has a
dictatorship South
Korea has the Western modern
approach and how it
prospers one of the most Progressive
countries in the
world Samson phones hondai cars Kia cars
hondai make
um large
ships massive container
ships
and it's just a very very
thriving country and yet North Korea
people don't have enough
food they have to clean monuments with
small tooth brush type
brushes they have to pretend that
they're
happy and they're in a doctrine that
they're told how to
live how they should
think when I go to Russia in the past
even as late as
2019 please don't say anything political
about our
president in
public you never know who's
listening they still hold the thoughts
of the communism era of when I went to
Czechoslovakia when it was in the
Communist
era and even the Dorman on the
hotel would tell somebody higher up than
them in the hotel and it would get all
the way back to some Superior person
[Music]
where the person who spoke out against
the government or a company boss or even
somebody in the hotel they would be
reprimanded and
punished I've gone off track a bit but I
do think that
um
iido will only
be
achievable in what hanu and
Shian
Desires in those countries where people
are still have
nothing great to live for outside
their lives that they're suppressed
[Music]
in and as they grow and become more
westernized and find the things that
we've found around and are happy with
they will be fast forwarded into
the the world of not having any
time they want instant coffee
iido but it's our job to try to help
them the best way we
can most of the teachers who went
through the period I did and again NS
Shan I would I treasure that and it
cannot be repeated in my
opinion I don't have enough time on this
Earth at my age now I perhaps have 5 to
10 years at the best I'd like to live
longer but I'm trying to be a
realist if I get into my early
80s um I'd be very happy
so therefore let's say I've
got let's give it 10
years reading his words when he talks
about starting off and then in a few
years you get to this level and in a few
more decades you get to this level I
don't have decades to teach the students
what they need
to no I can only teach the same as all
of us teachers
we can only teach the best we can
now so I think
personally
let's try to not force iido on them like
a religion where they must bow at us
always call us Sensei always um be there
before class sitting in ceser like the
little
soldiers but also don't let it become
too laxed
where you think as I have lately what's
the point in teaching
them they may be actually better
philosophers than us they might actually
be better understanding the concept of
those senses IO than
us we learned the
technical we learned the
fitness the endurance and all the other
points but we never really learned the
spiritual people are fine of the
spiritual because they think oh here we
go we're going to be talking about
religion and all
that but the spiritual can
be about
you try becoming a better person look at
your weaknesses look at your
strengths you know list your faults but
don't beat yourself up too much about
it this is the spiritual path to me that
we should
take the old words do unto others as you
would do to
yourself okay so improve yourself the
best you
can don't think that the past if you're
living in a western modernized world
where the pace of life is really going
fast don't think that you're going to
turn the clock back or else you'll
become a
dinosaur you'll be a teacher of
something that will never work it's not
going to happen go
forward
become a good person yourself become a
student and not a
teacher and just tell others what you
think is good for them to improve prove
themselves not to tell them what they
want you think they want to
hear I have got in the
same big mistake hole as most of
us we're on the map they're doing
techniques and you're going well done
yes that's good when it's not good at
all is it it's not good in the in the
regimented hardcore way
that we were brought
up I remember with cyto sensy I followed
him for 27 years but 19 physically twice
a
year and once he said do you know ense
he only ever acknowledged that I was
okay once in the 24 years that he
followed him he only was
acknowledged that his iido was good
enough
once that was in the hu Dojo where
Sensei was told never to
show the a weapons because I sense he
felt that they'd already destroyed his
Tai Jitsu and he didn't want them to
destroy his
weapons and
once uh C Sensi arrived thinking that o
Sensei was on the
train but when he got to the hood Dojo
her sense was nowhere to be
seen so C Sense he went against those
sense's
wishes and he taught them
weapons just to find
that towards the end of the class a
sense's figure
appeared on the edge of the door
frame
he said he was absolutely
petrified because not only had he broken
his word but he taught weapons and no
sense he saw
him on the way back home in the train
ensei said to
him it's okay you teaching
weapons so that was the only time he
said that he was ever told that isido
was
good and
now in one class one seminar how many
times do we say that's good well
done we're giving the well done some
goods and Praises away as if they're a
large bag of sweets and we're trying to
keep the students all
happy so if you can go away from a
teaching a class or a seminar or
whatever with one thing that you taught
yourself not
through watching the students teach you
something but something you may have
said or something you may have done that
you've had a realization and you've
taught yourself something that will
improve you will improve your
thinking then to me you're still a
student rather than a
teacher this is my
ambition but to do this I need students
because it's a technical art where we
need movement and we need people
attacking us and grabbing us and doing
all the things they
do I don't need the comradery I don't
need the dedicated students I don't need
anything apart from being able to
complete my
journey and for that I need human
beings so rather
greedily I'm telling you from the start
of the set of films to this one that
it's a
journey it's an amazing
journey all the things that you don't
fit in in life and all the things you do
fit in in
life if you find what I've found and and
others I'm sure around the world in
iido then we perhaps have touched o
senses
iido because what it's done is it's held
our attention it's made us meet
people we've traveled perhaps places we
would have never traveled
so looking back on the Journey of life
aido has been a wonderful wonderful
thing to take part
in so I hope you have enough to consider
this and those of you who may be
listening to these films in the
countries who have not yet reaped
the wonderful things that the Western
world has that
others who criticize it the dictatorship
countries or they want to do is have
wars to control their
people punish their people if they don't
conform the ones that I feel saddened
for every
day but hope that one day the world will
be free and then they will all be
doing oh senses iido because they will
have found love
Harmony and flowed with the best that
they could while they were on this
planet so consider how you
teach
but
giving is a
reward but the reward must be also given
back to you thank you for listening